all right let's talk about a couple of
other little side stories that are
taking place here one of the interesting
kind of contrasts or conflicts that has
arisen over the last few days is the
contradiction between
anger that Donald Trump has been
arrested and the claim that this is
really great for Trump well if it's
great for Trump then wouldn't someone be
happy about it but yet all of the magas
are Furious and they say this is the
biggest and most injust miscarriage of
the uh justice system if it's great for
Trump then you'd think someone would be
happy about it so this reached a sort of
fever pitch yesterday and I'll just give
you one example although there are many
Newsmax anchor Greg Kelly said that
while under arrest in police custody
Trump looks even more presidential if
you can imagine it you know sit up there
uh visiting with the with NATO
or on during a state dinner with the
Prime Minister of Japan no no no no no
no
you were at your most presidential while
under arrest in a ratty New York City
courtroom here is Greg Kelly listen to
him say it
president Donald Trump this was
technically in police custody today
going from processing into the
arraignment
and somehow he looks even more
presidential
the brown-nosing is giving me cringe
Greg I'm sorry serious I mean we're
talking Eye of the Tiger this is why so
many people are drawn to him he fights
and by the way this is this is all
nonsense right I've seen the indictment
and it's a joke it's even sillier than
we thought oh by the way could you
imagine Joe Biden being in this
situation could he survive could he
Thrive Donald Trump just gave an amazing
speech in Mar-A-Lago tonight we'll get
to uh the details in a moment some
highlights but first the Democrats they
wanted this image to be totally
different they wanted the defeated
broken man or under arrest they wanted
somebody like like this guy dsk when he
was arrested I mean that looks pretty
bad or this guy who allegedly I think
killed his parents his father I mean
that's the same table that Donald Trump
was sitting at today or this guy
recently arrested I mean this is what
they thought Donald Trump would look
like instead you know what it looked
like
he was back on The Apprentice there's
nothing damaging about these photos in
fact it's damaging to the people who put
him there okay it's they will be exposed
in fact they already are exposed right
so listen here here's the bottom line
there can be TR there can be truths that
seemingly conflict with each other but
don't so for example
I believe it is true that Trump's arrest
helps Trump in the Republican primary
and it helps them in two ways I do
believe that there are Republicans who
have been kind of disaffected by Trump
who maybe were planning to support
someone else or not vote at all in the
primary and some of them will indeed be
activated by Donald Trump's arrest
because they've been convinced it's
unfair or whatever the case may be so
that will help Trump in the primary the
other way it will help to Trump in the
prime areas who on Earth has mentioned
Ron DeSantis in the last week Ron
DeSantis name which was very much front
and center in the news is essentially
gone so good for Trump as far as the
primary is concerned if Trump wins the
primary this does not seem to be good
for Trump and in particular if there is
another indictment this is the exact
type of chaos that surrounds Trump that
doesn't get him a single new vote in the
general election and remember Trump lost
by like 8 million votes in 2020. and so
if he's going to win in 2024. now yes
granted the the difference in the states
that made a difference is a much smaller
number that's always the case if Trump
is going to win in 2024
he needs to find some new votes or the
Democratic turnout needs to be lower
which may be and we'll talk about that
in on a different day I don't believe
that this arrest gets Trump any new
general election votes so these people
are really parodies of themselves this
is the new thing it's great for Trump
trump looked so presidential sitting
there at the defense table uh certainly
in the eye of the beholder to me he
looked angry in the video where he was
entering the courtroom and he looks kind
of dejected while sitting there at the
defense table but everyone is going to
see in it
to some degree what they want to see and
I understand that we'll see ultimately
what this does for Donald Trump